[Music]
why should people be concerned with the
issue of mass incarceration people
should be concerned with the issue of
mass incarceration because it is a human
rights crisis that is happening right in
front of our face and it's being cloaked
with you know crime and punishment so
these people are bad people they've
committed a crime so we can ignore them
we can lock them up we can throw them
away and we can basically ignore a large
swath of our population because they've
been criminalized as bad people they're
disposable human beings are not
disposable right we have value all right
we have traumas we have you know you
know hearts we have families we have
communities so we're not disposable no
matter what we've done we're not
disposable okay so you have you have
prisons that are privatized but in
addition to private prisons even
state-run prisons you have corporations
who are profiting from people's
incarceration so what does that mean
okay the thirteenth amendment in the
Constitution in the United States
Constitution it says that slavery is
illegal so you can't have slavery
anymore except for punishment of a crime
so everybody get your Constitution out
look up the Thirteenth Amendment and you
see the clause that says except for
punishment of a crime so if you are
committed if you are convicted of a
crime then you're exempt from that
Thirteenth Amendment saying that slavery
you know is abolished so that means that
you're allowed to work as a slave slave
labor slave wages so you have people
working for 10 cent an hour 11th in an
hour who are armed you know doing
agriculture working for huge
corporations
you know I don't want to name them
because there's so many but you know a
lot of the goods and services that we
take for granted clothing lines you know
computer parts airplane parts military
equipment food that we buy
organically-grown these things are being
manufactured in prisons in prison farms
in prison you know factories by inmates
so you know we talked about oh you know
by American yeah okay I have this line
in my play the peculiar patriot and I
said okay well made in China made in
prison is now the new China
you know because China you know people
with outraged about all evil slave labor
and you know these sweatshops and you
know in Taiwan and China you know all
these unfair labor practices you know
overseas well it's happening right here
in America being made in prison so you
have corporations companies who are
profiting off of people incarcerated so
there is an incentive for hyper
criminalization of a population to keep
capitalism running on a well-oiled
machine of slave labor which is the
foundation for this country let's not
forget that this the fabric the very
fabric of this country is rooted in
slavery slave labor for hundreds of
years so there is huge capital that was
amassed systems and industries that were
created from slave labor so how does
this system continue to operate well it
just kind of shifted and now we have
mass incarceration we have people who
are literally working for five cents
seven cents 10 cents an hour no labor
unions the workers comp you know what I
mean so it's a corporation's wet dream
and I think that
if we were to examine the slave industry
because that's what this country was
built on right okay we can't ignore that
it did not come out that this country
was not born out of slavery like good
industry of slavery and you had people
say oh my god how do we have slaves for
400 years and just the violence in the
atrocities and the trauma and it was
just oh that was so horrible right okay
so that happened but there were people
who said no this isn't right this is not
how human beings are supposed to be
treated and the human beings shouldn't
live this way so if we had abolitionists
who fought against the system of slavery
chattel slavery I think that the issue
that was just as important during the
was at the 18th 19th century right I
think it's just as important now that we
are faced with the same human rights
issue of the day and not marginal
remember down during slavery we had
people who thought oh well this is just
the way things are and they you know
went to cotillion and they went to
parties they went to a little you know
business as usual and you know people
just kind of ignored the stench of the
plantation and what was happening to
other human beings and you had some
people who were like oh this is not
right this is not right and the people
who said this is not right they were a
small section of society and that voice
got louder and bigger and stronger right
so I think that we're at the precipice
of a great another great shift in in
society where you have a small group of
people who say this prison industrial
complex is a human rights crisis
something needs to be done you have a
lot of swath of people say Oh
they're just criminals this is that what
we have to have prisons right but I have
faith and that small voice of people who
believe in humanity of people who
believe in a world without prison
becoming louder and louder and louder
just like the abolitionists did back in
the day
[Music]
you